[ YouTube Learning ]
How much money do you really need
to start shooting videos at home?
Zero!
You heard me right!
You may have heard about fancy cameras and
fancy lighting, and great equipment,
but you don’t need ANY of that
to START shooting videos at home
The only thing you really need
is the determination to start.
[ Don't Memorise intro music ]
Remember that it’s more important to have great content
than to have a huge expensive production set.
Let’s first talk about the simplest setup
possible!
To start shooting videos at home,
you just need your smartphone.
Because nowadays, all smartphones come with
good quality cameras.
But is that it?
Let me give you just 4 tips
that will help you create great videos!
First, good lighting!
And you don’t need fancy lights for that.
The best lighting out there
is natural light or sunlight.
Also, remember that if there is one light source,
then it should be in the front of your face.
It shouldn’t be behind you.
How do we know if the lighting is good or
not?
This, for instance, looks good,
and this, not so good.
Also, if you are using a board,
especially a whiteboard,
make sure there are no reflections
seen on the board.
To avoid this,
you could just place the light diagonally across
and not straight towards the board.
Second, good sound quality.
Make sure that there’s no background noise
when you are shooting videos.
Turn off your TV, close your windows
and try your best to eliminate
all external sources of sound.
Another common problem when it comes to sound
is ECHO.
The best way to avoid the echo
is to make sure you’re not in a completely empty room.
Echo occurs mainly due to the reflection of sound.
How can you reduce the echo?
You could have carpeted floors,
you could fill the room with furnishings,
and you could also use thick curtains
to cover the walls and windows.
If you want even better sound quality,
then you could possibly invest some money
in buying a good external mic.
Let me give you an example.
This is how it sounds with an external phone-mic,
and this is how it sounds without an in-built phone-mic.
Third, good framing.
Framing is all the things your audience can see
in the frame of your video.
That not only includes you,
but also your background.
Don’t be too close to the camera
or too far away from it.
And have a simple, clean background
without any distractions.
Treat the video as if you’re taking an actual class
for your students in person.
You’d want no distractions whatsoever, right?
And lastly,
the Stability of your smartphone.
Your smartphone needs to be very stable
when it’s recording a video.
You could buy a tripod
as simple tripods are available for cheap.
But if you don’t wish to invest in one,
you could use books on a table,
and then use your laptop for stability.
Now there’s a possibility that
you want to go one step further
to create better quality videos
using some advanced equipment.
What I am using right now is a DSLR camera on a tripod.
Now let me show you 2 pictures on the screen;
one taken with a cellphone
and the other with a DSLR.
I’m sure you noticed the difference.
A better camera will give you sharper and
crisp images,
unlike your smartphone camera.
You can also use a zoom lens along with it,
which will help you capture zoomed-in video
without making the video look grainy.
The DSLR camera also has a sensor
that is far superior to the sensor
in your smartphone camera.
That means it can handle many more lighting situations
relative to your smartphone camera.
I’m also using a good wireless mic here
which gives a crisp sound quality
and also eliminates the noise around.
Here’s how it could sound with a regular
mic;
and here’s how it sounds
with the current mic I am using.
You should note that
the recordings that are generated using your DSLR camera
are stored in an SD card
which is present inside the camera.
These recordings can then be transferred
to your laptop or tablet using a card reader.
Now some of you might be wondering...
what if there are some parts in your video
which you want to cut?
This part is called EDITING the video.
You will not believe
how easy it is to do this.
There are plenty of free editing tools available out there
that make it so easy for you
to cut parts of your video.
You could also shoot many bite-sized videos
and merge them together to create a longer video.
All of this and lots more can be done easily
using Editing tools!
I’ll share more details about editing tools
in the description of this video!
So… how can you begin?
My suggestion would be to start off using
your smartphone,
and once you start uploading videos consistently,
the love you get from your audience
would automatically make you invest
in better equipment.
So what are you waiting for?
Shoot your first video,
and share it with the world!
In the next video,
I will tell you how you can UPLOAD your videos
to your YouTube channel.
See you there!
[ #TeachFromAnywhere ]
[ YouTube Learning ]